I'm gonna cry in my ankle.
Wah!
It's up.
I think it's up.
I've just booted this freaking game
and the music!
Oh my gosh!
Are you there?
Hopefully I'm live.
I know I've started like nine minutes early
but I'm just sitting here
and I'm like,
I don't want to wait the nine minutes
for when I'm supposed to start my stream time.
I just want to start now.
So I'm starting now.
I just need to make sure I can see I'm live
and then I can close my stream.
Okay, yeah, it says I'm live.
I'm so sorry I've been boozled.
Yes, I put in the wrong date.
I put in the wrong hour.
Shocking behavior.
Um...
I have
the most kind of like
saddest start to a stream so far.
Um, I got on Marshmallow
but sadly due to text
I cannot see what the tone is behind
and I've read that Marshmallow
is like a veiled threat or something
but I just want to say
to the person who sent me a cat picture link
like an actual picture of a cat
um, I don't know how to break this to you.
I got my payloads in March
after a very rough time
where I realized that life was too short.
I've not owned a pet.
Okay, since then
and my payloads came into my life in March
so please, like,
I don't know if it was like a weird threat thing going on
and I know for literally everyone else
this makes no sense
but I can't read tone in a text
and it looked like a weird veiled threat
and I just like
I got my payloads in March
and yeah
I don't know what to tell you
like I've visited America as a child
at nine years old
I don't live in America
I don't know what's going on
so you identified yourself as not a refling
so if it's all good
I'm just gonna, you know, stream here
with my reflins and we're gonna do our thing
um, hopefully it wasn't actually a threat
but if it was
then hey ho, I've addressed it
and I've negated what your
evidence was
purely on the basis that I got
Gimli and Vigo in March
and that's when I got my payloads
so yeah, I apologise for that
making absolutely no sense
to literally everyone else
but good morning, good evening
and good afternoon
it is a wild ride
you play two games of Assassin's Creed Brotherhood
I'm literally not even on my third game stream
I've never done a second game stream variation
and it's like oh
I don't think it's a threat
but at the same time my brain's telling me it's a veiled threat
so I'm just gonna address it that way
if you didn't mean it, sure
but as I said
I don't live in America
I have two cats
that I got in March
they were adopted and
yeah, I don't know what else to tell you bro
I'd just appreciate if you left me alone
and I'll just
be having fun with my reflins
so thanks
don't do that again
um
yes, anyway
now that we've got that part over
Jesus
a little bit of a restless sleep
may or may not have had diarrhea
because I can't tell context
however
we're gonna be playing
a game
called Needy Streamer
Overload
I just opened it up
and it gave me a kind of Windows XP thing
Windows Vista was like
before me I'm like
99% sure
wait, Windows Vista
I don't think I even had
wait, when?
wait, this is Windows Vista
no, I think Windows Vista
when
released it
oh
would my dad have had that on the console?
well
let's give it a
Windows Vista
or Windows 98
I don't know what version of Windows, okay
so we're gonna have a shot at this game
I don't know what to expect
now a few reflings told me yesterday
that for a factoid
this game apparently has over
500 different endings
or I made that number up because someone said
the game had a ton of endings
now this is gonna be a shorter stream today
but the good news with it being a shorter stream
is I
might be able to release
my first ASMR
1k thank you audio
today
but I need to go edit it
but it's gonna be fun and it's clean
it's clean ASMR
it's literally me just rambling
and tapping away on stuff
and all that kind of thing
so it's cute
just a short 9 hour stream today
I'm sure you can strap in the lads and lasses
then you worry
only 7 hours, yeah
I was actually thinking Skyrim
I've put down Skyrim as 212 back to back
I don't know
if I should purposely wake up
right before stream for the Skyrim
and then make a second room
and then we'll do like 12 hours
and then in the second room another 4 hours
and then I think the following day
that 12 hour stream I can complete
the full achievements
I'm not 100% sure
I do have a honey tea with me though
so hopefully you have some water
some snackies
and all that jazz
but yes, next week
our endurance stream is going to be
Skyrim
and we're also doing an endurance runescape
old school runescape
I will tell you what world to be in
I am going to start on a fresh account
I am going to buy premium endurance
but we'll get to that when we get to that
you know what I mean
so let's stream into it
yeah, I'm a bit fatined
for streaming
really enjoy it
like some people
due to their circumstances
they can't stream every day
they find it a bit harder
and mentally it takes its toll
me?
um
like
I'm about to try out this crazy game
for the first time
I don't know much about it
apparently you can do implied
scenes in it
so I'm like
here we go
so I'm interested
I don't know if it should just get straight into it
you guys can hear it
it's not too loud
I was worried about the music being too loud
I can almost turn it off on my end
but yeah
yeah some streamers like
just do it circumstances
but I just seem to have the perfect mesh
of like missing brain cells here
a bit of a smooth brain here
a bit more of a complex surface area
of the section of my brain
music's actually a bit quiet
right okay
it's just loud in my headset
okay
I've turned off a bit
I'm a wee bit close to my mic
but
right
oh it's got a little love heart
see that
so Mersey was theorised
that her heart
right this is what I theorised when Mersey thingied
Mersey's pupils
are normal
before
her first
experience as a yandere occurred
and then
her pupils broke
and she can no longer love appropriately
like the concept doesn't exist for her
if you look back in
Amy's lore video
you'll notice she
her pupils are normal
until she picks up that book
hey little small details
obviously my pupils have always been
the little cuddle fishes
she's broken
I started to realise
that if someone has a feature
within their entire brain
it's just soup
honestly
I would happily join
the
the study data group thing
you can hook me up
because I can prove that
I'm pretty dumb
like yeah
I didn't think to pay attention
no there's like
little small details
like in everyone's lore like
you know
Aisy
has
scars from the polar bear
that she destroyed
and then she raised
feral
and like
kind of like
all kind of plays back into it
like
for Aisy's
audio work
she's actually
babe this is going to sound
terrible
I'm so sorry
this is going to sound terrible
in
my
experience
if there is ever an audio produced
where you
listener
may or may not be taking
have been
taken
by
banpage of
the female performer
it always goes down really well
and I consented Aisy
with the idea that she doesn't
know what
bincent is
she doesn't know what
she just jumps on you basically
no prior warning
because she was raised feral
so it's not a thing like
if you're a bear
you grab what you want instantly
you want to eat
okay let's go down to the river
you want to claim this tree
heck yeah let's claim this tree
so yeah
and
I kind of made her like that
I've not made her do anything like that
but
it's just kind of like a small detail
because everyone's like
oh this brat needs correction
or like oji-san you can't keep up
and it's kind of
interesting to see that dynamic form
because the dynamic in my head was like
she completely has you wrapped around her
claw
type thing
and she does what she wants to do
which is so terrible
but look this is a fun thing about
like going from concept
to actually what's happening now like
as I said girls I've full control
type thing going on
my update for YouTube monetization
my statistics have updated
and we've been told
like I can see on my YouTube
that I've met the watch hour
when I go to apply for monetization
it says I've only got 88 hours watch time
and I'm like
right it's been four days
I would like to apply for it now
like I have no idea why it's taking so long
to update it's crazy
crazy
I'm going to take a sipping tin of my tea
and then we'll see what this game provides
yes so I am warning you
it is a shorter stream today
however I do think
Shibi is coming on in two hours
I think A.C. is having a rest day
Shibi
and me is a rest day for Azura
I think Azura does double back rest days
what kind of tea
it's always the same tea
it's a British
like I think it's called black tea
or English breakfast tea
either variation with honey
but once having a tough time sleeping
is a gist thing
no Azura is doing ASMR
oh my gosh she's doing ASMR today
I'm so excited for Azura's ASMR
please give her lots of tips
unironically
well in three ways
monetary
your advice
and the other
I am
she's so nervous but I know she's going to do perfect
like imagine listening
I can hear it now imagine that voice going
by neural ear to ear
and kisses
and I hope she hugs the mic
I don't tell anyone what to do
but if she hugs the mic
heartbeat Azura
heartbeat and kisses ASMR
from Azura
I'm already on cloud nine
I don't know what to tell you
also I may have infected
Azura
and Shibi
they said they might play Assassin's Creed brotherhood
in a later time because I've inspired them
and they remember playing the games
I'm going to be fangirling
so hard
if I get to watch them play brotherhood
but good morning
good evening
good afternoon or good time zone
like that one we fling said
no better feeling than chilling
your childhood game
I didn't know Azura played that game
because
she spoke a lot of watching anime
in her 2.0
so I was like okay
on a scale of gamer to weave
I'd say she was a weave type thing
we aren't
real we fling's youtube is telling on us
ahhh
evening you
let's spread the AC love oh yeah
spread my AC all over your face
so Johnny you maybe want to replay
it's so good
we are going to revisit in october
but my morning has been good
my pants have been chat
if you haven't smoked
aww I never got a marshmallow
from a fart
from the toilet
I don't think he is here anymore
I think he is in the national cryo chamber
unfortunately
but like
but iknie started her stream yesterday
and she was like
Oh and I did it this morning
it's got a really weird marshmallow
and I'm like
can upset or offend anyone or anything like that. I'm like I can't read context so my
brain's like is someone threatening me? I don't know. But yeah, bizarre. Bizarre.
Ripterbiel one-pants shitted. Honestly it was fucking weekend, I'm not being funny but
it's absolutely, you know what, you know what, it's a British word that I don't use often at all
but I saw it in a tiktok recently. That's Pongen. Like P-O-N-G-E-D. Pongen. Pongen. Pongen.
So smells. It's such a bizarre word. I don't say that, I'm just like, that's Rican. We say Rican.
R-E-E-K-I-N-G. Rican. Pongen. Oh I'm sorry, that sounds Dutch. Pongendjunger.
Hello. Mingen. Oh yeah, Mingen. Rican. I say Rican for smell. I think Mingen's like more disgust
but Rican is for smell. I'm British, you've never heard that. Pongen. Like when it pongs,
I wonder if it's an older word. My gran. My gran, I think she said, oh that's Pongen.
Although she made me laugh one time. She calls farts Windy Pops and I was like,
and I burst out laughing. I've never heard it being referred to as Windy Pops before and I'm like,
I don't know, okay. That's like, it's so polite and so British. Like if we end up getting a British
Virgin too, I'm making her say like, ooh Windy Pops, like in our wee English accent. I'll say
in that we could get a Welsh or Northern Irish, Irish. But sometimes Northern Irish don't really
want to be referred to as British, you know. And in a way, I completely respect and understand
like, let's not get into it. Wait until you learn. Wait until we do the history stream
of why the Irish famine, potato famine wasn't actually real. Thanks to the British Empire.
It's ridiculous. But yes, if you didn't know a lot of Irish migrated to America,
a lot of Irish migrated to Scotland, to different parts, to in search of working food.
Which is why a lot of you are like, I'm one eighth Scottish, I'm one eighth Irish type thing.
Heck yeah, you are. Because that's how mass migration worked. So you know that one eighth
Scottish in yet? That's right. I'm in you right now. I mean, I'm in your blood supply. I'm beating
around there. I'm seeking things in your body because you're like one sixteenth Scott.
As a British person, a lot of things were up for. Well England, with its sanctions on Scotland.
Please don't take strunnies in me. Oh yeah. I thought it was meant to be the other way around.
Look, it works both ways here. That's all I'm saying. Look, some people, look, some people didn't
like it. I respect that. Okay. All I'm saying is that if I had some sort of sensory organ,
it would give me more of a reason to explore even more.
One fourth Scottish, let's move actually. What percent campfire will we tolerate?
I see the most common.
I have 3% strunnie in me. There we go.
The potato famine was not fun for Ireland. Well, wait until you learn even more about the issues.
Maybe we can do an education stream about it, but I don't want it to be hate because I assure you
any English twat the day did not have any bearing on the famine.
But I don't mind doing historical education streams. The reason why Ireland kinetized them
with Scotland is because there was mass migration due to that. I don't mind a cheeky education stream
once in a while. I've actually really always enjoyed academics. Sadly, the social sides of
academics, I may have failed that part, but I've always enjoyed it. I'm actually going back to
college soon, which I'm excited to talk about. Not now though. Man's trying to run a business.
Well, I say that. I'm actually passing off it. So it's everyone else's problem, but mine.
But I am thinking of doing beauty school. But listen, hear me out, beauty school dropout.
That's a grease thing. The reason why I'm doing beauty school is because I want to get a certificate
to possibly, possibly open up like a little, so you might not know this. You know in salons,
like they have like a spare room. These rooms can be rented out for whatever you want.
And I was just thinking on the idea, like when, you know, time progresses, things,
things do their thing. I might have a pop up like little ASMR shop, but it's like just a little bed
in the room and it would just be so fun. And I love it because I am like genuinely passionate
about ASMR. Like I love the stuff about it. I've like tried to research some of the psychology.
I've came up with my own theories. Not everyone like agrees with my theories, but that's because,
you know, that's just what it is. But I think it would be a lot better. V sucky salon. Right,
you're done. You're done. You're done. You're done. Honestly, the skills you've learned running a
business is worth much more than the MBA. Well, you see skills, but literally I'm at the process
where I'm about to hand everything off now. Like I'm so freaking happy. And the only thing I need
to worry about is clippers. And there's the possibility for those of you who have an Oshi
desk and editing skills of the girls, I am 100% open like once things set up, because I know it
takes a while to kind of settle on an Oshi and be like, oh yeah, shit. Yeah, I'm going to watch her
consistently. If you have the time and if you're an editor, I am very open. If you wanted to be a
dedicated clipper or highlight editor for that girl, you're welcome to email the website.
Just to tell you right now, no, you do not get a open communication with a girl.
Everything is done through IWL messages. But yeah, if you really enjoy one of the girls and you
want to clip them or do highlight streams or funny moments type thing and want to get paid for it,
hit the website up because it saves me even more time because right now I'm today after the short
stream, I'm going to edit my 1k, thank you ASMR and then upload that. And then I'm going to send
away a few more clips for editing because the second guy we've got, poor guy, I've like left
him on red for like six days now and I'm like, oops. But yeah, I'm definitely gonna have to find a few
more clippers. I probably want to try two more clippers. But yeah, you don't like Vsucky, so you
would say that Vsucky blows honestly. But yes, there's opportunities. Like please don't think
that this is like a super closed off like thing. Like I'm happy to tell you about what the process
is like when it comes to clips. Like the reason why subtitles kind of jump at you in clips is
because that's what gets the monkey side of your brain to like keep watching. The editor for Mercy's
recent clip, I forgot to put credit in the blonde one. You can edit credit in the description.
Right, I need to do that. Mercy has a new short coming out and the way the editing style is just
captures the ADHD perfectly. It has insider knowledge about VTubers and like just really happy
with it. So if you can edit what Mercy's recently published clips are like, feel free to hit the
website up. I'm needing a few more clippers. I'm needing to get Sheeby needs clips very badly. I
need to put up. However, there's like so many little notes. I'm like, so I've told the girls to
cover up your for now. Like as you can see, you can only see my deck leotage at the moment,
because I'm a bit worried about what the heck's going on with YouTube right now.
I feel like there's still policy of these going, but that's just me. But right, let me finish this
team. We'll actually jump into the game because I have been yapping for 20 minutes. I'm not even
stop. Oh, that's ridiculous. Sorry. I'm so sorry. Goodness gravy. Once I get started, I can't stop.
20 freaking two minutes. That is terrible. Are you looking for clippers? If you look on
Mercy's most recent short, if you can do clips like that, that's pre made stuff where I just send
you the model and the audio and then you do the subtitling and all the other fancy like
then yes, definitely apply. If you mean clipping highlight sections in general, I again,
I'm going to I'm going to see what happens after a girl to stream.
Okay, I finished my tea. I came for the yapping. Honestly, don't worry. There's two
point. I was like half yapping, but it's so fun. Yes. Okay. What is this game about? Good question.
I actually don't know. So all I know is it's called needy streamer overload. I believe it is one girl
and there's a ton of different endings that we can potentially get. So we're going to check it out,
see how it is. I believe it's a click simulator. So I can't get annoyed at the gameplay because
this is my kind of thing like nice chill, doing my things. Veal over the company competition is
actually just who's the biggest yapper. Honestly, 20 minute talking, no gameplay. Honestly, this
game is each of our life simulators. Actually, okay, that's good. That's good. I was going to
play YouTube simulator and then I was going to call it like well, real or fail. Okay. Okay,
so there's day progressions. Okay. Okay, you ready? Welcome day one of five.
Man the way. No. Got the stream account. Time to log in and get ready. Click on stream and
log in with my... Thank you for the tip. Joshua Jones, 22. Oh, there's a cat. Oh my god.
Click on stream and log in with the password angel kawaii who? Log in. Oh wait, like angel
kawaii 2. Sorry, I do things phonetically. I see you've logged in. This is it. We're...
This is where... Oh no, everyone knows I can't read now. It's got too fast. We'll be together no
matter what happens online. Whether I die or I get arrested or I break or I get stabbed or I get
flamed or I become god or go crazy. Virginia, thank you for the tip as well. That's got to
happen. The main reason I'm here for overall, thank you for the tip. We'll be together no matter
what happens. Oh, the internet is truly the festering cesspool of heck born from modern society.
But even so, I have nowhere else to turn to. Are you squidding me right now? Dr Resurgence,
thank you for the tip. You're awesome and I love your accent. Thank you so much for the tip. I appreciate
it because I have trouble getting out of bed in the morning. I don't want to get out. I don't want
to get a proper job. No, she's a need. No. I'm scared of other people. Adults pee me off and I'm
bum bum. I'm dumb dumb. And I still want everyone to fawn over me. She wants to be an idol and
streamers get fawned over and the most over the most right now. Oh god, everyone knows I can't
read. So that's why I want to be one. Thanks for sizing up all my gear and getting my stream
software running. Pete Chan. My name's Pete. Heck yeah, my name's Pete. When I send you a DM,
you can sometimes pick your own reply. When the time comes, make sure you think long and hard
about what to say. Pete Chan. Pete Chan. Yep, you're my Pete Chan because you're so, oh,
wait, we're the manager. We're the manager. I mean, you're the only, this is the people that have
been emailed on the website. That's all I'm going to say when they're like, I want to be a talent
manager and they have no thanks. I mean, you're the only person in the world who understands and
supports me and you're my one true love and you're also like my producer so fit. Oh, that's
so freaking smart. Okay, you're super smart. No, you're super smart for naming me unlike me. So
you can guide me. You can tell me or anything and I'll do it. Let's do this. Let's do this. Let's do
this. Let's do this. Let's do this. Let's do this. Let's do this. Let's do this. Let's do this. Oh,
it's almost time. My makeup looks good. Got my wig. Perfect. Here we go. Here we go. It's time
for my first and go. Wait, this is late. Wait, this is good though. That would not have been cheap to
do.
Nice, cheery, cute. What? Stream is usual.
As usual. God, you're so cute. Cute. Kawaii ne. All right, so we're playing mod simulator
on ironical. Wait, YouTube mod simulator. Choosing comments. No.
Weird name.
Array of light illuminating the chaotic internet of today.
Bringing happiness to the nerds floating in this electronic sea.
Can I type myself?
Wait, so she gets stressed if I miss stuff? Oh boy, here come the nerds in the comment.
We're all here just to vibe. So don't be mean. We're all just here to vibe. There's no point
of just starting calling each other nerds. We're all just trying to enjoy ourselves.
A promise of future peace. I'm a little manic and moody, but that's all right.
Don't go depression on us. Is that mean? I don't know if it's mean or not. I wouldn't care.
I feel like I'm deleting all the comments. Go get therapy. No, right. No, don't be mean too hard.
The internet angel has descended. Thank you for gracing us. Cheers. Yeah, read it. Oh,
I can tell her to read it. Okay. Okay. Okay. Let's go. Let's go. Huh. We got a little Minecraft.
Wait, wait, wait. Get out of here. No, don't read it. Delete it. No, no, no, no, no, no, no,
delete it. You silly sausage. No, don't delete it. Why? Oh, what was that?
Or do I tailor to? Okay, I don't. For goodness sake. I'm a rubbish mod, honestly. So when you're
going to show it, see, I would leave that in because I've been like, I've got bikini models.
I'm the terrible mod. I feel like I don't mind. If it's a way for you to get your stuff out,
I'm sure. And while I'm at it, I'm going to be the biggest streamer on YouTube. That's a threat
and a promise. Oh, my God. Threaten is more Kangol. Is it Kangol or K-Angel? I feel like
Kangol sounds like Kigo. Right, group Kigo exercises replaying. You've got my support.
Go back or go home. So I'm going to shoot for a million. Jesus, lady. You've got my support. Yeah.
K-Angel, Kawaii Angel. Oh, Pepega. She literally, an interesting newbie has appeared. No one even
freaking types newbie like that. That's ridiculous. Show us what you've got, baby.
Hmm. Hmm. Anyway, there's still a lot I have to. Anyway, there's still a lot I have to learn,
but I'm still going to be here. I can't wait to meet you all. I think that's what she sounds like.
Nice to meet you. To meet you. Nice. Time for a challenge.
Thank you for greeting us.
I'm K-Angel. Get out of here. Oops. I don't think I was supposed to do it. You get out of here.
Oh, and if you're a backseat gamer, do me a favor and stay away please. Well,
what's wrong with freaking getting your hand held? They're games. Nice to meet you. Subscribbled.
The birth of a legend. First stream complete. At the end of the stream, I will respond to the
comments you choose. The fans love that, so aren't I so kind and generous? I guess. Twitter.
Hi, everyone. Wow, this is my first. This is my first time meeting all of you.
I'm only going to each one. You're Internet Angel. What did you guys think of my first
stream? I hope you like it. Oh, I can't read that fast. Jesus. Oh my God. Oh my God. I'm still
shaking. Did you like my performance on stream though? So when she, her voice is deep here,
K-Angel finally descended upon the world after we spent so long mulling over it. We've got a
thousand more subscribers, huh? But that's not enough. I want more people to fawn over me.
We're only just getting started. I like the bunches. Best design. I need at least one million fans to
satisfy my desperate need for approval. That's crazy dialogue. I wonder what Dev team made this.
We got to get that. We got to, we got to get to that within our month. That's the most motivation
I've got. Oh, she's done it in a month. So let's get this, let's make this month count.
Okay, we have 30 days. We can make K-Angel the biggest streamer in the world if we work together,
right? Uh, uh, yeah. Yup. I love you so much. Oh my God. I really hope we can pull this off.
I'm counting on you. We're going to make it happen. It's her dream. We have to make it happen. I might
break if you push me too hard, but when that happens, we can just destroy the internet.
And anyway, I'll be counting on you tomorrow too. Good night.
Wow. Okay, so it's a 30-day sim. Okay, okay. Day two. Day two. All right, all right.
Good morning. It's my first morning as an official streamer. Wait, it's already noon.
Uh, I'm just not a morning person at all.
I was a bit, I was a bit too slow on that. Oh, well, anyway, since we're aiming for one
million subscribers, we still need 999,000 more. But first, let's start small and go for 10k first.
We'll get there in no time. And as you know, I'm completely useless on my own.
Haha. So you need to tell me what to do every day. I know you'll make the reddit, right? Is this
terrible of me to say? But as like a manager point of view, that's actually super easy to direct
people like this. Like, just tell me what to do and I'll do it. So I'll do everything you tell me.
Really, I have complete faith in you, P-chan. I'll follow all your orders perfectly and I promise
I'll become the best streamer. Literally, I like feel so bad. But like, this is like the perfect
employee. Because if not, I think I'll break and fall apart or I could break you. I don't want to
be weak. Oh, fuck it. I'm fucking her. I could break you myself. Yeah, you could. Oh my, wait,
she reciprocates. Oh my god. Oh my god, I'm sorry. I'm sorry, my penis typed that on the keyboard.
I'm sorry, I couldn't. I'm sorry. Please don't be creeped out by a manager. Right,
how do I tell her? Are we done? Hang out. Oh, okay, okay, hang out. New idea incoming.
Sleep. New idea incoming. New... medication. Oh dear, that's not good. Oh, she feels okay.
So I'm definitely mental darkness. Wow, okay. Oh wait, what does that say? Collect ideas. Okay.
I comprehend. To collect ideas, I want you to search the internet for the current Twitter trend.
Of a VTuber model. Social media puts her stress up. Oh,
pre-streamer, vanity search. No, don't do that. Video streaming? No. What's ST? I don't know.
Dender. No, you don't need dender hen. Go follow the latest VTuber trend. I don't care what it is,
but go do it for me, darling. Someone I met for the first time today told me you looked like you
would be really into underground male idols. Do I really? The task manager will show you...
I'm learning, I'm learning. Conspiracy theories are always so interesting to read about. It's so
funny seeing people argue about whether they're real or absolute BS. I never get tired of it.
Okay, okay. You're actually so smart. I don't... Idea gone. But you know, I feel like if you go
deep enough, you'll end up buying into it sooner or later. Curiosity killed the cat kind of deal.
Well, I'm fine though. I never let that happen to me. I'm the most rational and logical girl in
the world and the only thing that drives me crazy is you. Okay, if it's reciprocated love, then I
don't feel bad about being weird. But anyway, I figured that conspiracy theories would make
for great content, so let's start this off with a banger. Okay, okay. We can only stream once with
the idea we get from commands marked with an exclamation mark. If we stream with a low-level
idea, we'll be able to find another idea on the next level up. Comprehend, yes. Go to dust.
Is that my only choice? I don't really want to cross route. Okay, it's making me go to dust.
I think I messed up your medifix recommendation because I was using your account to watch stuff.
I'm sorry. That's fine. We just... Wait, you can't stream... Do you actually need to go to bed?
Is she tired already? Do you need to sweep, little one? Or do you need to go again?
You want to do internet again? Pre-stream alert goes up. Our stress...
It will change time tonight. Okay, okay. I wanted to buy myself a super comfy couch,
but if I did that, I think I would never leave it. I think it would turn into a blob.
Go to night, and then she can stream. So she can stream at night. Can I want to dye my hair pink
something? I think even more people would love me if I did that. Pink is definitely an idle hair
colour for VTubers. Very common. I actually didn't want pink VTuber, but I think we'll
definitely have a pink one in general, let's be honest. Right, chat and chill. All hail the internet.
I think Zatsu. So this is her doing her 2.0, so we'll do Zatsu. Begin. Transform!
Honestly? I'm digging this so far. This has already blown me out of expectation out of the war.
Okay, very, very, very. Stream speed as usual.
Hi cuties! I'm the internet angel. Okay, angel. I kind of sound like, um,
what the heck, the rabbit from Sonic Heroes?
Why does she always say bless or whatever? Eh, clearly because she's...
You're blessed to have her in our life? You're so quiet. You're super cute.
I love the internet because all of the lovely people are willing to listen to you alone and
other attention whores. Parish! Why, angel? Thank you for your super chat. I love you.
I keep reading that as Kigo. I'm not even going to pretend otherwise.
Oh my biggest fear is the end and then I can imagine living a life not being needed by anymore.
No, this is too real. Oh no, we're about to put on Mr. Kitty as the hours pass on the
little notes that I hear. She sure is bold for a new streamer.
Do I need to speed this up?
She says she loves me. She loves me? She loves me now. She loves me. I don't know about the rest
of you, but your face sure is cute. Okay, well, I love it. This is the true mod experience. Honestly,
can I speed this up? No, I can. I guess. No takebacks now. Chin hands. Oh, this is chin hands?
This pose? I got Mercy have chin hands toggle. Because it's all over if you get bored of me
and I don't want to die yet. Let's go! I'm going to need water so quickly if I'm
I didn't bring any more. Please don't die. Please don't die. Oh no.
I'm bored. Why would you super tip? I'm bored.
Let's have a look. See why Angel? I kind of messed up the super chats, but I've always been an Angel
since I was born because I'm just too kawaii. Please don't die.
People die and whether I live or die is all up to my bet. Whoa, stay there.
Oh, well, you are streamed. Thanks to everyone who came along to stream today. Sorry, I was
too new to this. Love you all. I never caught on days when
Kegel streams. I'm so good. I can't read it. Right, Daisy, Daisy.
Dear P-chan, this is Saito from the bit creations. As per our last phone call,
your rent is still outstanding and you will have to pay. You have until the 10th to pay for it.
Oh my god, I'm going to get kicked out. Please forward your payment to the account details below
and contact me when you've done so. Regards. Please reply to this email with any concerns.
I'm sorry. What is this? Does this mean we need to pay all our rent by day 10? We're broke as heck.
We need to be able to monetize our content ASAP. We need to get more than 10k followers first.
Easy peasy for us. Let's go. Yes, yes, yes. Oh my god, you're such a hard worker. What the heck
is that though? That little bear thing. Right, I need you to... Your stress is really high.
How do I de-stress you? Hang out. Play game. Stress goes down by five... No, that's number four. That's
Four. Affection goes up between us. I don't want her to have to... What's this? Spend time together.
Her affection goes up and her stress goes down by six units though. I think we'll do that. No,
she needs... Wait. Wait, hold on. It says dot, dot, dot. Love is in the air. Stress goes down
significantly but mental darkness... Mental darkness goes down, affection goes up and stress
goes down. This is a win-win. This is the most po- like this is the best thing to make her feel
better. Sorry, but... Is that that game where it's like 120 levels? I promised to never portray you
guys, so please keep on showing me all your love. Oh, nori. Nori Nelly. Uh, what taken? No, what?
This shows how much pressure I'm feeling. I might start acting weird if I get too high,
so watch out. I may even become more scared of the internet by the day. Uh, this displays how much
I love you. I'd be sad if I don't love you enough but if I love you too much it might be hard to
handle to try and strike a good balance. This lets you know how I'm doing mentally, how well I cope
with reality will change depending on the numbers. It might have a bigger influence over my future
rather than in your future. Uh, show me one hate. Show me one hate or who bothers to wear clothes
that fit them properly. That's the most bizarre thing I've ever read. Uh, we're definitely gonna
have to research tomorrow. Uh, we'll do conspiracies. Why are you now? Transform! Time for her voice to
go like this. Men here have each of her simulator. Is that how it goes? I know there's lots of end
ends there. The fixer of who controls them? What is that even mean? First time here.
Oh wait, no, sorry. I'm reading parts in the voice app. I'm not supposed to.
Do you guys like conspiracy theories? I know, I do. Have I read about them? But why?
Young nerds love these. That's American viewer spot. Annihilate this man.
Is this supposed to go faster than this? Oh, I love conspiracy theories. I'm excited, yes.
Okay, do you like conspiracy? So, I can... Oh, that's going too fast. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Today I'll be talking about their culture conspiracy theories. Like the freaking, is it the ET game
that's like currently, um, dug into like a ditch and it's like 40,000 worth of games or something?
Some people say that I... Oh, this is going too fast. They wanted to do the Japanese masses
into nerds to numb them. Sounds wacky, but what if it did happen? I'm not a nerd.
Uh, I think we'll do a nicer super chat. I think we could do a super chat that makes
her happier than that. But then people get mad if you don't read them out.
Everyone watching now would be dancing to the tune of Three Minds Fonds.
Feels like you're going to eventually go off the descent if you...
What? Talking about conspiracies?
But it's okay, because even if you were off this...
I can't, I can't, I couldn't even moderate it. I'm not a nerd. I just want to know this what a nerd
says and she's gone just like that. Jeez, right. I'm not clicking that speed up option. My goodness,
what was that? You upped the stream speed, but I've tried to lure it, did I not?
Wait, is this her all? I will shiitake mushroom y'all on my privilege will all and will.
As long as one finds that they can stay blissfully unaware and even if someone does find it,
it's not like I'm committing a crime, even though it does feel like we're really just...
Wait, so this is her all. Oh, and this is her main. Oh, that's a shame. She doesn't enjoy streaming.
Then you do it then. So, but you didn't have to stream if you didn't like it.
I don't know why we're... Can you write some good stuff about
thingy on ST for me? I think it'll be too obvious if I do it myself, so please.
Medication gives her an idea.
Diazipam?
One milligram Diazipam makes her floppy.
Brof. Brof. It's five milligrams that'll make you floppy, Hen. It's not one milligram.
One milligram does nothing. That's a tiddly wink of Diazipam.
It's someone who's got the anxiety maze. I assure you, it's five milligrams when you're
gonna feel it. Right, I am going to let her get a new idea by playing games. She used to play some
games. She's a lightweight, literally. All you need is a beat a blocker and you're good to go,
and if you're really not good to go, Diazipam. I hit my gacha a bunch of already. We just paid
money for that. Did you just spend money when we have to pay rent? Nothing beats a good games.
Humans were born to play, and I'm getting the hang of this streaming thing, so I want to do
a let's play. Let's do this. Yeah, that's exactly what you're supposed to do. Why are these reactions
so scuffed? You have a new idea for stream. Let's play throwback stream. Hey, that's what I did!
Go dusk, go dusk. Right, you can play again. I want you. I need you. I need you. I need you.
I love you. I love you. Atama no naka. I don't know what the tune is, but I've probably heard it
if it's that popular Japanese. I'll let her play twice so she can get two game things.
Need to grind, need to grind, need to grind, need to grind.
So I put a stress by four and affection up, but I didn't do anything. I just remember this game
I played when, where you become a big shot, who is a global influencer or whatever, I actually got
so into it, I ended up skipping it. What game is that I referenced to? I just remember this game
becomes some big shot who has global influence. What game? That must be a reference, but it's so
generic. But anyway, I know it's recently a lot of people these days like to play games where you
have to rule, power to rule the world and even reduce population and stuff. What are these references to?
They must be references to. Is the game, it's referencing itself? Oh, Pepega. That's very plausible.
And some people also truly believe that's what's happening in our world and make up these wild
boogie men to direct their rage at. Wait, is this because I looked up that conspiracy stuff she's
saying this? I don't blame them though. I think considering the times we live in, it's not so
strange that people want someone or something to be angry at. Not as, not as dissect in human
nature. Hold on, this game is, I love it already. What the heck, we're like human nature, but we
should all be working together. Please, this is my only wish as an internet angel. Wait,
Bob, I'm, I'm eating this up for breakfast. Like, I love the intricate like one human nature that
you need something to do. Sounds good, doesn't it? Well, I'm going to say that and see how the
Schumer's react. They are my, girl, do not bite the hand that feeds my goodness. Oh no,
she was talking about theories. I didn't, only one cover. Wait, am I going to turn her into a
politician? Can I turn her into anti-migrant factor? Please, can I turn her into our
migrant factor? Stop, stop anti-migrant factor. Let's go. E-girl anti-migrant factor. We believe
in the public owning the fricking things and the private sector does not own or have stakes
and that the people do not buy out mistakes, buy out companies that go bust because it's not the
people's problems for the private companies. Oh my god, yes! Revolution, yes! Oh my god,
this game's amazing. Hi guys, it's Chloe Angel, the Napoleon of the Streaming Wall. Who's Napoleon?
Right, not you. That's a terrible super chat and you should be embarrassed, but we'll put it in
because we can take it out. No way we can do this. In 30 years, our world could be ruled by one body,
or so. Oh, we're too late for that. Conglomerates are screaming too cr- Wait, let's turn-
Wait, I can't turn it off. Uh, what's a conglomerate? I've done another rabbit hole. The division has
already begun. Oh, I haven't long ago. Conglomerates are scheming. They're even trying to reduce the
world population to one billion. That's scary. I want to live in an equal society. I'll put it in
because it's super chat, but we'll see if we can replace it with something else. What would the
world be like ruled by one government? I don't know how I feel about worshiping a fallen angel,
being an angel myself. Lucifer, hold that guy. You can be my fo- You can be my fallen angel. Sorry,
this is a chat. Keep fricking doing it wrong. Uh, I'm already taking action. You frown your face
is so kawaii ne. Is there any mean comments? I don't think I've seen any mean comments.
Like, literally we're playing the Biden number Isaac right now. We've got, uh, biblical references.
I'm kind of curious about that kind of world. Okay, we'll put that in.
Wow. I assume if I don't, like, if I skip this, I miss out on, like, she might get stressed.
I'll have a peek at the comments. That's scary. I want to live in an equal society. Yeah,
but then just sitting around and complaining isn't going to change anything. We must fight.
No way we're fricking starting a revolution as an e-girl, please. Yes, you can, uh, I shall be the
new, I'll be the new god of this world. Yes! Oh my god. Yes. How do I make her do more of this?
This is amazing. Oh my god. Oh no, it makes her shaky though. Oh, I don't want her to be upset.
You know what we're doing? You're always bound to end up fighting one way or another.
Those who do not fight will not survive. Look at my DM and stop ignoring me.
I'm sorry. Where's your webcam? Oh, sorry. Oh, I thought I can head pattern.
Kind of. Obviously, the first thing you gotta check that you can touch next is the section,
but hey ho. Oh, I can't head pattern. Take that. Yeah, you like that. Yeah, head pattern. Okay.
I don't think I can talk to you right now. I've just been focusing on your career, so it's fine.
Alex Jones feature for art. I want her to, like, take over the world. I'm going to make
an Amazon wishlist. What should I put in it? Bath bomb costume and expensive mic.
I'll produce that. Expensive mic. The people need to hear your words. All right. That's it. Yes.
The people need to hear you. So not Kawaii. Oh my god. You're so Kawaii. Oh, she's blushing.
So not cute. Okay. Okay.
If this is you complaining about me not interacting with you, my lady,
I have to say this is the most rubbish interaction I've ever seen before.
We are sending each other emojis and that's it. You're done. How do I make you do that thing again?
How is, what was the one that made her get that row? I want her to do that row more.
Her stress, oh, her stress is 61? Oh, that's so high.
Her mental darkness goes up on social media. I don't want that.
Daisling stops call makes you feel as a streamer's voice is a lifeline, but it'll take too many
and or stuff will happen. Okay. Everything just feels more manageable and it makes you feel kind
of floaty. Do we pop one? Fuck it. We'll pop it. What happens to her stress levels?
Madame. Madame. Madame. You did not have to post that on the main account. So her stress went,
wait, that was it. The stress went down by one. That was pathetic. Don't ever do that again. That
was rubbish. Oh my God. She's high as a kite. You are in no state. Is this this jump scare here
as well? You're in no state to stream. Yeah, you're in no straight. That was useless. You're not looking
at my DMs as quickly as you used to. Do you care about my girlfriend? We got rent to make, honey.
Get them Yurizou. I love you, but get them Yurizou. What are you talking about? Right. How did I get
her to do that? Come on, become a politician. Go on social media. Oh, wait, I think you just put
her stress up more. I'm really bad at this game. It feels like everyone is low on age. Is it because
of something they did? Also, please remember the streamer people too. Oh my God, I see that tweet
like all the time. Honestly, this game's pretty meh. I have to admit, like, I don't know, tweets like.
But then, wait, so how do I progress? I want more of this one. Take a dive into conspiracy world.
I'm not allowed to do it. Or am I allowed to do it? No, I think it regurgitates the stream,
so you can't do that. The next idea for conspiracy is on internet video streaming.
Okay, let's do a throwback to a game. I needed her stress is getting pretty bad. We're over 50%.
We're at 56% stress levels. Oh, I didn't mean to skip that, but I did. Oopsies. You got a lot more
stream ideas. Hey, cuties, I'm fine. It's time for me to come. Nice never gets old.
As usual. We're going to check out some truly ancient artifacts today. Well, like Assassin's
Creed Brotherhood. Goodness, gravy. I love games. I'm excited. What games are you playing?
The chat would like to know. Hey, I'm just doing my algebra while listening to she's back.
It's such a good adaptation. See, this is so slow, but the next thing is so fast.
Can I make her gamers? Let's go. That's right. Gamers are the most pressed and play some flash games.
Oh, I don't even remember any flash games, to be honest.
Um, fancy pants. I think it's the only flash game I remember playing.
He had like a mohawk and it was just like a 2D.
You look like you suck at games. And you look like you swallow at games,
you nasty. Thanks for the five. Going to a rent. Don't know what's going on, but I like it. Yes.
As long as you're enjoying yourself. What a lovely freaking chat she's got already.
Although her design is like, wow, this takes me back. This
site should be the one. Wait, huh? Don't TOS yourself. Don't TOS. What are you opening?
Are you all right? What's wrong? Oh, it's so old that support has ended and we can't play. Girl,
you're supposed to pre-open the game before string for this reason. Of course, literally.
That's actually in one of my rule books for the girls. I gave them a document and it said,
please open the game before stream to make sure you know it works and have backup games immediately.
Yep, there is folks. No, that was rude, I think. You're so silly. That's cute.
Lol, this is, this was more interesting actually. Okay, okay.
I literally, in the document, I'm like, please open. I'm like, don't cry.
Stop pandering to the old fucks on the internet.
Are we ages out here? Hold on a minute. I'm not. You're not reading that. That's not nice.
That's not nice. Or should I put it in there and then she'll address it?
Possibly. I'll put it in so she addresses it and she's like, we're not ages out here.
Like, we're just here having a good time, you know what I'm saying? It's okay, there's
all the same. You're lucky you're so pretty. You're lucky. No. Yeah, either you spawned in,
okay? You didn't pick the coordinates. You didn't pick what's going on. All right,
maybe I shouldn't have done that one. Oh, I don't know. Don't cry. Don't cry.
There are only three situations where it is appropriate for a woman to cry.
All right. When you get dumped, when you lose your wallet, and when your child's at Flash Games,
get discontinued. Sorry, I've got warrable if you can hear me rubbing that.
Stop entering to the old folks on the internet.
Shut up, my little lips. That's a cool way. It doesn't matter what age and gender.
Okay, yeah, she's sure I'm done. That's what I'm talking about.
So much for our first game stream. That's all for today, I guess.
Bless. Welcome to the house of Bless. Okay.
Well, that's it. What can you do? Things are only just getting started,
so I have to try even harder from now. Come on, I said stop ignoring me.
I'm 500 times more needed. Can I like like these so she knows I'm not ignoring her?
I don't know. My fiction 50. Our stress is so high.
We need to do something about that. We need to do something about our stress today.
I'm getting nervous. I'm getting shaky. Right. For your stress, go and...
Our stress goes way down.
And the fiction goes way up. But the thing is the stress goes down by like
what number difference is that? Eight? Whereas the stress goes down by six on that one.
I'm sorry, but a way... Oh wait, I need to talk to her. Sorry.
My new microphone's here. People have been calling about the sense, so this is really good.
Maybe I should take it with me to karaoke. Oh my god, yeah, I want to hear you sing,
baby girl. It's lovely time. Oh my god, you're so cute. I'm dead. This is so cute.
We'll be together in our next... Oh, are we doing afterlife? Yeah, yeah,
together in our afterlife. You believe in that stuff? Okay, right. To bed you go.
Go do your thing, baby girl. Let's get that stress level done, because I'm getting nervous.
I'm getting shaky. Wow, some... What's something you guys are really into these days? Minus the secret.
I love everything about... I feel like my brain's gonna leak out of my heat from
how good it feels. I'm gonna have... Right, we're at night. Wait, we're at night already?
Oh, for goodness sake. One day we'll be one of those couples that can afford to call a taxi
to go wherever we want. That is so specific. Yeah, oh my god, I would love that. Yeah.
I'm afraid you need to stream, but her stress is so high. I never even got her to get a new...
I never got... Are you sure you want to proceed? You'll miss out on streaming at night,
but I can't. I'm out of idea. Wait, she actually can't just do a zatsu off the top of her head.
Wait, what am I supposed to do? Am I to send her to bed? What's going on?
I already forgot what I told her to do. Is she doing something? Hold on, don't you?
What are you... What are you doing? Are you doing something? Is she doing something?
You can give her head parts. Okay. Oh, wow, I didn't know that.
What on earth? I'm kind of tired. Thanks for always being so nice to me. Yeah.
I should carry on your spirit and be nice to my little nerds every once in a while. Okay.
How do I reduce your stress?
Sexy stream. Her first ASMR stream. Let's go. Go to tomorrow. So we can't do anything because
we're like out of time. Can I like head pattern until like some of the stats go down?
I think she's doing something. Honestly, I was like, what's going on? Oh,
we're on day seven. Rent's due soon. Hey, what color should I paint my nails?
Light blue, purple, rainbow, black. I want to say purple because of her hair streaks and
her alternative outfit. Light blue and red for her actual natural self though.
Light blue matches her natural self more. I know black is like the thing,
but she is going to have to dress up for her stream. Oh, she's actually doing as I say.
You're actually such a good girl. You're so clever. Good girl.
I did my nails, aren't they pretty? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. That's what I was,
yeah, that's what I was thinking. Like, it kind of matches.
Gee, it's not even me that likes the color.
Well, a new black, uh, found a new girl. I like more than you. I mean, yeah,
you get new Oshis all the time. You're allowed a new Oshie. You don't have to say I've allowed
though. Um, you know, some, right, stress. Oh, forget to sleep.
If she sleeps, sleep until tomorrow. A new idea if I sleep until tomorrow.
Okay, I'm just going to send her a bed. We have an ASMR stream plan for tonight.
She's going to sleep. Okay. She's going to sleep. Let her sleep. Right. ASMR time.
Get the mic out. Get licking it, young lady. Okay. Did I make myself clear? I want to get high.
Oh, I don't think we, I don't think we're allowed to condone that. Sorry, but no,
you're about to do an ASMR stream and we need to make sure it's YouTube terms of service safe.
Okay. So no, you're not allowed. Go do ASMR right now.
Oh, hold on.
I forgot to get a new warble.
Subsquibble. Any subscribers? First time. Hi cuties. I hope all of you nerds are going through it
today too. Going through it. Like the Mr. K is the always best. I want to die. Whoa.
I don't think I can allow that. Sorry. I have put my hand over my mouth and shock
because I didn't want to, like, I'm not a nerd. But, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but,
but you're so good for always trying so hard. It's okay if you're chocolate.
Honestly, actually, I'm starting to agree. We're hold on a minute. She's actually kind of starting
to make sense. Like, sorry, but you actually have been told by the capitalist COGS that you
needs to be productive for every, here comes the most job or something. What? Eh.
You have been told that you need to be productive for every second of your life,
That's not true. You try harder than any of us
But personally I hate being told that just being alive is enough. It's just such an empty ass compliment
No, sorry, I'm disagreeing. Hold on a minute. Okay, Angel
You're starting to lose it get back on the politician bandwagon. I want you to take over earth right now
I feel that tell him I feel worse now
No, I feel like that's cathart. Is it car thorntic if someone like kind of just gets to vent and chat
I feel like that'll put her stress up though
But it's like cathartic to like put it out there to be like, you know what I'm feeling it, you know
Here we go, what is it?
Yo
I'll be your team yell. I'll be your team yell
Or smooch smooch is that what I'm supposed to say? I don't know what smooch you're my real life angel
Love
May that's what keep hanged off
I need stop I need stop. Can you take it off?
Yeah, we're gonna reduce that I give it a plus with my first kiss
I'm so happy then die
Thank you for the tip, but no, I'm not gonna
This pandering feels forced. It's weird. Is that gonna stress her out?
I think I think cuz we know she's role-playing it will thank you for this. Okay. That's much nicer. I
Don't want her to get stressed out cuz I'm already like struggling with her stress at the moment
She looks like Monka
Do it again, please. Oh, you're too cute
Yes, we're actually I don't know if we're gonna make rent. I'm gonna make you my girlfriend
This is oh, I always send the girls these like little symbols all the time in my messages and they're just
My little
Love love love and thank you for the super chat, too. I love a man who can send me both love and money
And thank you guys for you and I'll thank you guys for you
Why did why did you say that are you squidding me right now? Why did you say that?
They're all a thank-you kiss from you more
Why did she say that at the end of the stream?
Why would you say go die at the end of a super chat?
Whoa, I
Was so confused why she randomly came over that did you see he he did you all like what you saw the date?
If you did, let's play again tomorrow. What did some basic as pandering in my stats or skyro?
Oh, wow, I actually did our stress is so high after that
But the longest we around is a short sweet home right? I can't just ignore the girls
When you Twitter, I missed it. You guys are having
Overwhelming
Is that the end you need a head part
Is there a secret to the stress level thing I think I'm not achieving whatever it is. I don't want her to break I
Reach 10s. I want to do a celebration stream, but you know 10k is a nice number, but that's about it. Yeah, go for it
It's very I was actually speaking to the girls about this and the first step
I'm taking as a legendary angel, but I'm gonna get everyone to celebrate it and it takes back
You will love me for a little bit yandere. Yes, and
You have a new idea internet angel the internet and me thanks for taking okay that happened naturally
So I can fully de-stress her today without needing to come up with ideas
Wait, she's gonna get an idea for if I do this to her
It drops
Wait to gaming over she gets a new idea if I do this
I don't know what the thing is
Rest and touching grass like a real streamer stress management
Literally, we need to like take her out and go meet gammie. So she meets gammie things just even out, you know
Thank God they didn't introduce you to demonetizing
I'm not even monetized yet. They won't update my stats. She gets a new stream idea if I do this
And she doesn't if we do play
Internet it does her stress goes up exponentially
Mental darkness
Cine video streaming watch a movie
It takes her to dust you know what she's not actually sat and watch something. Oh, no, she's crying. Wait, you didn't want to watch that
I'm sorry. We'll be supposed to do something
I
I'm battling the channel page like the prison door screw monetize story
They just won't update this house. I don't know why like I can't the streaming site
I use update no other anime does it like idle anime truly and the best ones are the kids idle anime
I'm glad you love it
Well, I guess that's why the page of the TV is the best though, right for any TV shows
Really good inspiration for my streams. If there's anything you guys would like me to do
Let me know in the reply. So maybe I could do something that we can only have someone
A girl's idle journey and a kid's anime. Okay. Okay. Okay. Shake it off
stress is still faking high
I'll miss yeah, I'll miss stream if I do that
Is there an internet I
Only puts it down by four, but it gives her another this doesn't do anything
That puts her stress down by four and gives her a new news stream idea
That takes her to the next day now, I think we're just gonna have to do spend time together and put fictional
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Apparently with this credit card thing. We can no no no no credit cards are bad
They're not real credit. No
Don't know punch you. I don't care. You can beat me up and spit in my mouth
Do whatever you want you will not know peace. Oh my god. That's literally what I'm asking for. I love it
I love you so much. Oh my god. You just read my mind. Oh
It says read when she reads it. Well, that's kind of scary, right? Well
A faction goes up during game gamer girl goes up
Experience was up. Ah, maybe does make stress 67. That's better
Are we going for the end? I don't know what endings are I'm gonna play the game before click anywhere to give her that's more
Spend the whole day laser run. Oh wait, did I just skip stream? Oh
No, maybe
No, no, it's time to stream. Okay, my apologies. Um
Let's celebrate your 10k milestone cuz that's fantastic as I was saying before I got interrupted by my own thoughts
I actually said to the girls like unfortunately, like you kind of have to like celebrate numbers as they come through to like make
VTuber news or whatever and
Like it's really not I don't like playing that game
But you do have to play that angle as a VTuber and it's like a bit like
You got to do what you gotta do. Hi, here we go. Thank you. It's me
Wait, you're not reading comments for the stream
This stream is one to celebrate celebrate. What do you ask? Well, did you not read the title?
I can't do anything
I
Guess just get ahead of
Never just watch everyone subscribe we need to blow up
Celebrate with some tasty
I can't be the best, you know, I really hated adults adults girl are new 18 plus
I'm getting nervous
I'm good. So I'm good sway. What's going on here?
But they were all true to themselves
Why do I find you being a dropout cute?
They weren't ashamed of being into anime or manga. They were so free so natural
My god to myself I want to live like that. I want to live on the internet and be my drizzle
I guess I wasn't too interested, but I'm glad I could share with you guys. What's that?
You talk too fast for me when I put you on this mode. Jeez the stream is already over and do a dang thing
Hello
Look I draw some fan art. Oh, that's so cool
That's so cool
Getting fan or it's honestly crazy
Oh
Can I like save it or send it to her so she can see it just so she knows
Oh the nighttime trims actually really nice it reminds me of that Russian song that goes
She's 17
Oh, am I ignoring her DMs again? How do I ignore them by accident? I'm sorry. I love you. Please. I'm sorry
You get an achievement for like clicking her head a hundred times in the rope
Okay, that's as fast as I can click if I didn't make her happy I don't know what was
I can't I can hear that in the chin
Shit wait, she's actually 17
I
Very strongly think that any content career should be at least 18 years old
Sponsorships trying it in your drinks. I got dea. Oh, sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Oh my god. That's amazing. Oh my god
Love you. Oh my god. You're so cool. She's gonna know I haven't are you sure? Yeah. Yeah, this I'm so sure
Wait, what did she ask I didn't pay attention
I got dm'd about the sponsorship sponsorship as we enter in the big leaves
Let's see what it says. Uh, we'd like for you to review of our new
Natto wait Natto is that fermented soybeans?
Flavored cola and they said they'll pay me a year's supply. No
You have to accept US dollars for payment. You do not ever ever entertain a sponsorship
That say we'll pay you with our product. No
Hard-earned cold cash. Do not entertain
Respond reply. Okay, this is true. Yeah, why not a job's a job? No, we are not doing that stream
Absolute waste of time. I'm going to send you
To do that internet thing because I want you to become a politician but our stress goes up
Mmm
Her mental darkness goes up but her stress goes down. No, her affection goes down
We will do
Is is ST gonna give me the freaking politician angle. I want her to take over the world
This takes me to dusk
Congrats. I'll get monetized
Why are they happy about that?
So they can be her paper already down. I feel like
Wait, what's this this bottom book post? Oh
No, our stress goes up. No, we're doing that. You stress goes up. You go watch some cinema
I've been streaming a lot of anime by myself, let me know in the replies if you have recommendation
Lying around and watch an anime late late night anime is probably my favorite ever
Maybe I'll talk about conspiracy. Yes
Yes
Absolutely do it, but you know, I'm a little scared to know keep talking about it. You're gonna rule the world
You will rule the world
We you must you must I don't think I have to do it. No, you have to do it
But I don't think I have to do
Dwell too much on that. I'm plus I can't I guess believing in them is kind of like its own brand of happiness
please
But I think I'll talk about my crew for microchips next. Those are one of my favorite. Yes. Yes
Your PC's can scan the layout of your house. Yes. I remember watching a talk show once in this guy
He was talking about an urban legend and another guest
So you got microchipped into you and then the guy was like I could tell you but then I'd have to kill you was the most
They're pan-faced ever
That was what made me look into this whole microchip business in the first place
I guess I want to talk about it because of how plausible it is
Yes
Yes, yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes
Yes, I was so happy I wanted to be like on conspiracy not
I've been falling asleep with my eyes open. So if you see me doing that, please close your eyes
Please close my eyes for me. What the heck?
Yeah, I will
Right, I just gonna de-stress her because we already know what she's gonna do
Who's her stress up to post on social media, which is such a shame
Mmm
Video streaming seems like such a safe thing to make her like less stressed
I'll do that and then we'll stream conspiracy theory. Oh
Tiny spiny. Thank you for the tip. It's work time for me against Ronnie, but enjoy the game
You'll probably offer and I'm done, but I'll catch up later. Yes. Thank you so much
Unfortunately as a shorter stream, but yes have fun at work and thank you so very much for the kind tip
Appreciate it. Um, I love videos where the person just talks about what they like even better if you learn something new from it
Yes, agreed. I
May be a dumb dumb with mental issues and a horrific academic record. Wait, hold on a minute
Hold on a minute. Oh
And a bit too close home
But I still want to share all the things I've turned up researching these things wait wait a minute
Hold on a minute. She wants to do education streams
Oh, wait a minute. Hold on hold on hold on
I'm getting squirt mental Illinois
I'm going to do a stream talking about things. I like and I like
Am I darling little nerds like and to do that? I guess I'll have to start at the very beginning with nerds themselves
And I've already done plenty of research on them. Let's do it
Okay, why are these oh my god? Yeah, you're so smart for coming up with these ideas baby girls stuffy time
I can't even see you. Oh my god. You're so cute head pat head pat
Uh, right, okay, let's go to the night
and
The moment I get a single wrinkle. I think I'll end things. I
She's hitting the wall. She's hitting the wall. Oh my god. I'm orb
Is she okay? I like I feel like these are
These are just like such random emotes like as long as she's happy. Where you even paying attention
Yes, oh my god, you're so needed
Right, let's do it or stress goes up so much talking about these though her mental darkness goes up
But communication and rabbit hole go up so much though take a deep dive into the conspiracy of the world
But don't go too deep
But I want her to do it right. We're definitely gonna be on stress management, but
We're doing wait. Yeah. Yeah, we're doing it
She's fine. She's an orb
She's Orbo death
Wow, look at them nails. Hey, you changed your nails already. They're supposed to be blue like your hair color
There's little things
Subscribble on ear
That's technology improves by leaps and bounds perhaps one day we will all be my car
Oh wait turn it down, okay
Oh
Hey angel, hey, hello, hello
Hey, hello
Hi, hi, hi, hi, and you come and you come. What would her fan base?
Hey angel fan base maybe if she's an angel and you follow an angel, I guess so you're a worshipper really
Yeah, you're you just be fan name would be worshipper he goes, okay. Well, I can't yeah
Yeah
She's a streamer. She's needy and now we need to the overload of we can roll credits
Their name is nerds. That's what she said. Oh, okay. Okay
November
See it's so slow if you don't
It's literally so slow
If I don't speed this up, but it's like far too fast. I don't know. Maybe my things buggy
No, I don't know the game seems pretty like the game seems pretty put well together any clicker. No
Nothing's happening imagine cities of people being controlled by microchips embedded from birth
Going into the deep end. Yeah
I
Finally during work with work I can watch a game now
We're doing the politician route question mark or the conspiracy not route concert. I see you're also enlightened
Yeah, that's so scary. I got one of my arm. Whoa
Whoa
I've just noticed the music gets quieter when I tab over to do moderation stuff and then
That's a really good detail
I've got a microchip too. Oh
Is she gonna I feel like that's gonna spur her on to do more microchip to do more of these types of streams
another government conspiracy
Wait until you learn about that time
The ruling class could manipulate our brainwaves as we like we don't use our puppets. Oh my god
I don't want to be main controlled
No way you mean I could be brainwashed right now
Where's my tin foil hat exactly
We're going to be the tin foil hat gang. Maybe just maybe we already have those chips in our arms
You could not be suggesting such a thing my innocent vtuber
Idol angel k angel
Was that a scream how did you find out about this? Yeah, take that instead of the microchip thing
And the moment you act out of line some big shot could hit you or kill switch from god knows where
We'll be living under a dictatorship soon mark my words
We are all on a watch list right now
K angel branded tin foil heart hat marriage win honestly, I'm not going to be able to sleep after this
I don't know who crafted it, but
As if that technology could exist
relax people
Thank god
It's trying to cut those branded tin foil literally just get tin foil the cupboard that was that was scary
For now anyway, oh her eyes are starting to change am I noticing that?
I'm actually gonna leave that one
I'll leave the dystopia one
But yeah, but her eye her eyes changing or if I just made that up
Please talk about this forever k angel. She's going. Oh my god. I'm loving this right
It's the music going up because she's going this rick. I don't remember you're not like the other girls. Yeah, she ain't
I'm gonna make sure of it. I feel like I'm gonna fall really hard for k
Oh
That click mouse button sounds like the legend of zelda minish cap raindrop splits or slime droplets. Let's have a look see
I don't want to be mind controlled
Scary isn't it? It'd be scary if we were real though. How did you find out about this?
Um, why do you ask am I being interrogated the government must have sent you to kill me wait girl
Bless amen amen in the charts
Why are you guys saying bless or whatever it's because we're a cult though
Bless we're called blessed
Literally get them hand emojis out there bless couldn't come up with a better greeting greeting. We're about to be out. The call is forming
Oh
I should really like a scream being incorporated into the music. Oh, look at your bless. Would you
She did it. We do have to maintain
Help me the microchip of my arm is controlling what I post uh
Microchips are like whatever because even without them you still can't prove that we actually have free will
Oh, she's at breaking point. She's at breaking point. Definitely
De-stressed day today. Hello pumpkin spice
I believe this is the biggest de-stress or I can do to you right now. It does take me all the way
If we miss a day of streaming it takes it to 65 or if we do that it's 71. Oh, it's still quite high
I don't want her on edge though
Oh
These didn't do anything if she takes the third one it gives her an idea like a psychedelic
No, right we'll do
We'll just do this. I know it takes us tonight, but I really want her to do
Uh
Oh, I keep ignoring her messages. I'm sorry. I keep forgetting. I'm so sweet like
I'm so I'm like, I'm I'm super like manager in this right now. I'm not like vtuber
Manager groomer. I'm like proper manager. Like I'm gonna make you successful
I get some blue DMs from guys some oh my god me too
on marshmallow
Don't think I haven't been seeing what I've been getting
But let me let me just say that this is not okay. I mean everyone's like wait what?
But that's the best part
Okay, we're doing ASMR
I never thought about doing it in my k angel outfit for proud
I wait
Ah wait my clothes are finding crumpled. Do you think that'll be fine to go on camera?
Oh well if I exit, please. Oh, wait. No, this is a regular. Oh well if I sit on the fascia. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa
I mean
I mean true
But like you do get suspended a little head pat because you're
Here's a good flag. You're my good flag, aren't you?
Oh, here's my good flag
Not click bleep
Nocta can't lick
Jesus lying down and it's a super comfy
I think I need to get a water and a cola
I can't the words are mashing together and now I can't get up. Come please help me. Yes
I'm freaking I would think I would get a cola and a water unironically
The words start mashing together if I read for too long
Our stress goes round and round. Is there any stream that doesn't put your stress up? Like I don't feel stressed when I stream. Is that bad?
Do we have to skip honestly? Do we have to skip?
I think we skip and do ASMR tomorrow
Um, no, not the medication. I don't think that's a good route for you darling because if you start relying on it
67 to watch
something
65 to play together or
Yeah, no stream. We'll do ASMR tomorrow. No stream
Let her take a day off. Yes
Can't really I stream every single day. So I'm not really sure what this is saying
If I ever find my special someone I want to go to the amusement park with them
We can scream to scream together. I scream together right the first rule. Why would you scream?
Oh an amusement park. Sorry. I thought I meant a park park like that one in New York City or something
I was like, why would you scream there?
Uh, I made up a p-chan. I made up a p-chan and then things got a bit what wait you made up. We fell out
It's cut is she like super lovey and dovey
Monetization oh she got monetization. Congrats. That's perfect. You're amazing
Ignoring you. No, you're not. You're literally freaking sending me emojis
Uh, we won't we won't get convict
evicted because
Those online nerds can pay for our rent. Jesus dodged a bullet there. I don't want to have us
To stream out on the streets might I really need a cola
I need a freaking I'm gonna go grab a cola in a war. I'll literally be a second. I'm like
Oh my god, I can't there's so many words the word
I don't know if you guys get this
But if you read for too long, all the letters start merging together and it's like it's really hard to take a
Like a context you of one heritage the actual word is
Period I don't know how you do it. Maybe you're a bit different though
And yes, I did just keep talking once I walked out there and probably didn't even hear me
I got my cola in the war. I'm going to take a little sipping tin
um
Put my blanket around me again
I'm actually wearing underwear today. I can't believe it
It's a christmas miracle
But I'm not wearing a hoodie. I've just got my my blanket like a like a poncho like a poncho
These streams are always a blast to watch. Yeah, are you ready for the rabbit hole route ending?
I actually kind of I'm interested to see what the other
Endings are. I don't think I'm going to do the other ending
So please don't get excited for a strapped in big long stream or anything like that. Um
I think I will happily watch what the other endings look like. Um
Let's take a little water sipping tin. Um, if you are
Remaining seated, please do wiggle
Move your foot up and down
And if you feel your calf muscles flex, then that's good because that is helping the circulation in your legs
Just do a few of those and then you're good to go
See you later. Bye. Bye. Thanks for hanging. I appreciate it. Uh she be cotton bum 30 minutes
She be cotton bum 30 minutes. I will redirect into her though. So don't worry about 30 minutes
Hmm
That's what you better wiggle
We're increasing that blood circulation for you
Wow, oh, I just realized I can't hear any game sound at all right now. Is it because did I tab out?
No, I guess it's the end of the day. So to symbolize it's the end of the day the music stops. I was like, where is it?
Uh, you know some things may be cliche but they're cliche for a reason like this
Welcome home darling. Would you like to have dinner first or a bath or me?
Uh, wait, is this because affection is so high?
I think so
The music is different as well and she's animated different. Okay. I like I like this kind of detail like these subtle things
Oh, wow, I'm like appreciating this game
Oh
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Did we just we were supposed to do any smart? I didn't
Oh, no, she's gonna be crazy for me. She's gonna go freaking yandere
Oh my god, I don't want her to go yandere. I need to like ignore her a little bit
I don't want her to go yandere. I want her to go political decision
I
No, no, you have to you have to stream you have to stream
Oh, no, I'm I'm I'm freaking I
I
Successfully gripped my feature for talent, but I didn't want to
Right go stream
ASMR, please. Okay. It drops affection dramatically doing ASMR. That's good
We'll do that
Go be unafectionate for your freaking manager because that's highly inappropriate. She's like yandere on me. She's called mercy mode, aren't you?
You're too good. I'm too good in this sheet. She can't suffering from success literally
Wow
Oh, her eyes are different. Am I going crazy or am I just making up that eyes are different?
Hi cuties, is your favorite? Sorry. I just drank a cola. So it's your favorite internet angel, kangel
I love you. Oh wait. No, it's a chat. I love you
Okay, we can do super chats today. I can see it now
Hey
Get off what should we talk about today? Oh, I know I've got a bit of a trivia about the corned beef
I ate yesterday. What are you talking about?
Is this relevant to the ASMR is this relevant to the ASMR stream?
I don't
Oh, yeah, corned beef. I've never been so interested in corned beef before
Wait, please talk every day about corned beef
Okay, her chat's actually really funny. I'm I'm gonna give it to them
Corned beef a smart literally
Did you know that corned beef is shaped so because of old canning methods which would
Is her heart pounding? No
Is her heart pounding because she's so in love at the moment
Good stream, but that's all it was just good. Um, that's a backhanded comment. So we will remove it because that's not very pleasant
Don't you be nervous? Does this thing have scenes? Does this game have scenes that I need to be nervous about?
Does this game have scenes that need to be nervous about
I
Subbing for sure omega lull
I did not know that was gonna happen. Hey, don't look you can't
I didn't know okay the game's safe. It's safe. Okay. Let's see. I didn't know if it was gonna go any further
You've just got yourself a new fan
I suppose I could give you a small oh
My god, that's so me when the bikini freaking toggle came on and I'm just me when about typing like
Even nois
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Okay. This game this game
Um, I know it's early days because we haven't finished our route, but I want to say this is 10 out of 10 already for me
This game highly enjoying it highly
Literally flush emoji flush emoji momento
This is so good
You you're gonna get big I can feel it. Yes. Okay. I thought I read that. Thank you mother for having me
Thank you for spawning me in on the same timeline as you stream
You just made me smile for the rest of my life
I suppose that's a nicer compliment than I give you a reward
But if she needs to pay rent and get more equipment because we got that microphone
I will never forget this stream for as long as I live
Don't worry. It's already been archived eight times over. You don't got worry
Can you do a workout stream?
Oh, is there like a fitness route? That would actually be kind of cool. You can like make her buff
I feel like you're trying too hard
You're out you will not hurt my streamers feelings
Guess this makes you an arch angel for now. Oh
Pisinga
Wait, wait, wait. Let me read that again. Guess that makes you an arch angel now
Uh, oh that didn't work. Oh, no, does that work? No, I'm a freaking no my freaking thing doesn't work
Oh, my freaking brooms doesn't work. I'm so sad
No, stop stop giving me money for something so small
You feel wait take my memory wipe beam
Oh, my freaking sand boards dead. I don't know why is that I hear
Come on guys. Oh, someone's message me. Oh
Oh
Amy is such a fucking hard worker, you know, hold on hold on game game
Did I accidentally go a little overboard? Uh, yeah, you're just popped it
Uh, hmm. I got way better numbers showing a bit. I wonder how that worked 10. Hmm. I try it truly a mystery
Uh, can I talk to oh wait, we got our goal. She wanted 100k. She did it. Wait, we want all ready. That's not right
Did she not want 100k or
This is my first time reaching so bad. I don't know what's gonna happen for you. I'm a bit nervous feeling
She wanted a milk. Oh hen. That's greedy hen
Hen you're supposed to take down the capitalist cog of greedness. Okay
I need to thank them for their devotion. Yeah, I think she's gonna get yeah. Yeah, yeah
Definitely do a thank you stream because that's like insane. What we will do is nothing affection wise
Uh, definitely stress though
Yeah, we'll just make her watch two videos in a row. I think who goes there identify yourself
As long as affection doesn't go up
Then
I'm happy I was watching this idol video and they were all eating popsicles for some reason
I already know where
Oh
ASMR
Oh, she's wanting the ASMR route, but I'm wanting the different route. I don't know how to get the freaking politician
I want the politician route
Is she okay?
You look so annoyed there. Here Jester asked me what I do and I I was like lol. I'm just a voice. That's what I was saying
If someone ever makes small talk with me, I'm just like I'm just a voice actor
It's so much easier to explain than be like
Uh, I mean I'm an anime woman on das interwebs. Yeah
I'm just like, oh, yeah
The scottish voices and demand all the time, you know, I get to play big strong women in my audios
Meanwhile, my audios are like, yeah take it. Oh
Oh
Can't she go outside for stress relief possibly
I'm dead. That's so cute
It's so cute. I'm dead
So not cute. Oh my god, I'm so sorry
Love forever. Did I just do that and then she's happy
Is she like talking to herself when she does that or is that a reflection on
Um
Right
If I sleep until night her mental dark. Okay, so sleep gets rid of mental darkness. I think we will do that
That's lovely. Yes. Just have a wee nap. Hey, you've deserved it. We rest
Okay mental darkness
I hate this
shaky
I wouldn't say
Are you okay?
Why are you looking at me like that? I woke up on record time this morning. Please breathe this morning
It's nighttime
Selfie time
You're such a girl honestly selfie time
Wait, so why is that highlighted? Give me this
How do I unlock this? Does it tell you how to progress or is it just it happens?
I want rabbit holes so badly
But don't go too deep
No
Right, we'll do thank you for 100k because that is
Very special milestone to celebrate and it's fantastic. Just got a look around the ideals
You have to find it. Oh, okay. I think conspiracies would be not in a video
I
Need to play that Russian song
Don't politicians usually have high stress and high mental darkness
I thought she said she wanted to become like some sort of
Uh
What socrates
I feel like a philosopher to rebuild a new world. I thought that's the kind of route that that angle took
That's what I'm trying to get. Well, that's what I think anyway. I don't I don't actually know
Because I was kind of like, oh, let's be anti Margaret Thatcher
and like public in like the resources
Of the
Nation need to be in the hands of the public and all that kind of thing
Yeah, yeah, I want to make her a god. Yes
I want to create you've grown so much as an angel. Wow, that's your channel grows so fast. I
I'm an angel that came down from earth from heaven to save everyone on the internet
Default setting too strong. I feel like you've said something similar before
Oh, I can't believe it. I can't believe streamer repeated one sentence
We're not reading comments for this stream. Thank you for coming to bless us
I like how she's uh, that's it's so gross down here. You should go back to heaven
The internet is oversaturated with users and content that it's hard to tell what to believe in
Yes, you should do more conspiracies whenever you whenever you feel lost. I want you to know that you can believe in me
All right
Save us my angel
And the whole believers will be whoa, we're doing the rapture all believers will be saved you just need to have a little faith
As the internet angel I will always be by your side
I just says exactly like that one russian song
Beginning of a coat coat coat coat coat give me a coat give me a coat. I won't call ending
I'm so glad we got tinfoil foil hat merch. I wear all the time when I watch your streams k angel
Whenever you feel the world mean is crushing you or when you're anxious or if you feel like you need to cry
Just come on down to my channel and I'll be waiting here for you with a smile
That's actually
Really nice. I think that's a good sentiment
Your smile is bright enough to illuminate the hearts of all 100 k of us
She
She don't say she I'm not gonna fail if I don't get her the numbers in time
I'd like do you always get the numbers and it's like a unique ending whoever
Strongly blessing us with ink in this universe
This game gives Valhalla
I've ever played that game
Oh, is this simple?
Uh
Obviously
I know what it feels like to have nothing and no one
La la
I skipped school a lot, so I didn't have any friends. Hold on. I don't like when she gets a bit real
Only the people online cared about what I had to
Fuck it up. I used to sit on xbox and skip school because uh, yeah, I had to have a rough time
Let's just get out of that. Hold on a minute. Hold on a minute. Hold on a minute
Honestly, I feel like a lot of VTubers probably had a rough time socializing and like that's how
They've got the internet culture like be a VTuber in the first place
Or is she idle?
She's not VTubers. She she's just idle
I didn't need no angels had to go to school too
Valhalla is a great experience. How many ever big game we game endurance game
She's VTuber coded. I was gonna say
Try and stay humble and try and stay humble. Hold on a minute. Hold on a minute. Uh, right can't relate to that part of it
Anyway, uh, I also got my son out for being socially awkward. You could have messed up in the end
Social awkward, yeah
Did I ever tell you uh at my job? I actually didn't know it was polite to say good morning to people
Like that's how so socially inept I was like I had to learn to say good morning
Which is why I like saying good morning. Good evening. Good afternoon to you guys because like I'd like to
Think that hopefully like you do get to learn things with me like overtime as long as you have faith in me
I will find you within the darkness
uh
Yeah, like I literally didn't know I was like you say good morning to your cool workers
Like a dumbass and I didn't know that that was like socializing and really common
Guess that makes you an archangel now, haha. Oh, that's strange
Or is it just to signify?
Remember you're never alone
Bless we are joining the call the bless call bless call bless call
K angel having 20 concurrent 100k falls creepy part of the game, which is oh unbelievable unrealistic
I can't promise to save everyone because that would be a lie, but if there's just one person to be saved by my person
can I would say it's worth
Oh, she got fan art
Oh, she's greeting. No, didn't cry we in
Didn't you need to cry? Why don't you draw a cry in?
Only time you're late to draw me crying is because
uh
I'm just so happy with that act we did previously
If my still if my smile can grant soul salvation, then I will keep smiling for all the viewers on the
Are we changing her personality as well to become a god?
I can't uh play a game do q&a raid a gigantic turtle around shinjuku
No, I want her to do the conspiracy theory
Uh
None of these are conspiracy theory for later. Yeah, okay, okay
I hate this wait did her stress go up there?
Her affection's still too high for us she's like doing this weird thing
How do I find do I find the idea here?
I put your stress up her affection down and mental
But maybe it'll give us the freaking I want the the freaking politician
Oh
I
Just found out an author that I've like ever since I was kid watches was strange like a dream come true
It's mostly these make me so glad but she mean I'm happy that one of my favorite was the most
When I replied he was like do you want a video called the disappointment a fellow that
I thought this is where I'll start for the mental who says that anymore, but conspiracy
conspiracy, please
Oh my god, what did you think?
You ever get curious about what crazy things people have done online in the past
I reckon I could turn my past crunch into content or something
That's like watching your debut stream
Like definitely vTubers watching their debut stream for the first time like over again
Like since after a while has passed like I do agree like that's good content
Uh, I wouldn't mind showing our mock streams if I wouldn't show the girls mock streams
But my mock stream I actually did better in my second mock stream attempt than I did in my debut
Um, and that's fact. I'm happy to show it earlier time
It's a good idea, but uh to be honest, I just don't really want to do it
Oh, I just make sure think and it makes people want to die, but the suffering is what makes it interesting
So I guess I got uh being a streamer so hard
girl
Being a streamer
I'm not putting you in any way
But then again, maybe the stars have aligned for someone like me like I know it's not
Can we not stream today day off day off day off? I need to boost off some steam. Sure
Uh, right if you're genuinely not wanting a day off, that's fine with me. Um, I'm gonna drug you up and see if that
Oh, she's gonna get so messed up
She's gonna get so messed up and it puts her mental darkness up to 32
Are you sure?
Yeah, like you wanted a break pass out on these drugs. Have a good time hen. Enjoy yourself
Three milligrams of the azepam will not do this here
Oh no, oh no, I thought you were gonna go to sleep
More than the sweet release of death, I crave the sweet
Sweet follow account, but still why is living so hard?
I guess I'll pop a few pills before going live
What
Breakdown stream. No
Get offline get a break. No, you're getting you're getting closed. You asked for a day off
I gave you one and you give me breakdown stream
Where when I woke up the sun was already set and I still feel so lazy after sleeping so much
Can I just sleep forever? Uh, you're probably feeling what's known as the side effects. I'm sorry
Can I just sleep forever rest for a turn eight? No
Sure. Do you want to sleep again? That means I don't have to bother living in it
Oh
Is she off on her not I think I'm I think she may be off on her not
Is she okay, I don't think we should have done that one. Oh she can go out
Oh
But who's freaking affection off wait akibata. Let's visit nerd culture popular with young people. Oh, this is actually really cool
So can we map?
Giznyland
You akibata akihabata
Shinjuku wait, so it's this shinjuku book. I mean, all right. Okay. Okay
Maybe that's where our politician
I forgot sick women
Give me politician. Just go to sleep. Just go give me politics. Just sleep one more time
We're going to stream you absolutely so it fails tomorrow
The moment I go about all these horrible memories come flooding back to me
Oh, because you're on 28 darkness
Oh god, I'm so sorry. Oh, that's so sad. Oh, no, you can't
Oh wait, there actually is an ASMR category. Oh, oh that's so cool
Okay, that's really cool
My silver award is getting for your fur. That's amazing. Okay, that's really good
Wait, but there's actually ASMR. Oh, you're so fantastic. Oh my god
You need to reach 80 mental darkness to prove
Oh
How
I need to make her mentally you want mental darkness 80
That's so bad. How do I do that?
That that's terrible. How do I do that?
Is it this one
Uh, oh, I really wanted to do the freaking I wanted to be a god
But all these I'm going to run out of time in order to
Oh sugar. I didn't read that in time
Oh
Mental darkness
Okay, that's so cool. Love it. Bye
Netlord no
Wait ego searching ego searching. Does it go to us? Yeah. Yeah. Love you. Love you. Love you. Love you. Love you
Let's make you crazy. Make you crazy. Make you crazy. Make you crazy. Make you crazy internet
Do ego search ego search ego search because it puts your mental to 31. I'm hardly raised it
Wow, that's it's amazing. Oh, yeah
Yay
Hey, it's so high
Check if any of your streams increase mental darkness. Good call
Uh
Okay, that one ASMR increases mental
Mental darkness goes to 39. Okay. Okay
I don't know anyone's gonna watch a breakdown stream though
Um
39 39 for
Sex streams. Well, yes, if they both do it, we'll do that one
No breakdown time. We'll do it. Uh
Was it ice cream looking or something?
This is such a good animation, honestly. Well done as a dev team
Who goes there?
identify yourself
What me eating ice cream, honestly? Hey
The negative comments increase mental darkness. Oh, you're right. No increases stress
Hi, thank you for joining. We are currently trying to make her a god
Oh my god, wait, they actually animated it. They bothered to animate it. I didn't I didn't think they were gonna do that
You know what else is creamy and drips all over?
Reflings are you in her chat right now? That sounds like something you would say
I wouldn't make her the god of ASMR
Yeah, I was gonna say ASMR brings mental darkness. I'm not sure about that one. She's saying
Uh
Hey cuties, I brought some ice cream today
Hey
I am
Uh
Would that bring mental darkness or stress? I'm gonna leave that to see if that brings a mental darkness
I can't wait. I can't wait to like
We just I'll speed up because girl you take it to them
You
ASMR reduces stress to should lower mental but yeah, let's say like I'm ASMR students are just like bing ching danger man
Okay, we'll remember. It's pretty fuck
What are you eating? It's a milk popsicle
Mmm
I've been expecting this. What are you freaking star wars quoting right now? I've been expecting you
I also love ice cream. What a wholesome super chat
Oh
It's so sweet. It's really everywhere. It's so much better than I thought
Uh and the fact that you skip most things you love to see
Hey yo reflins, that's when you use super chat and that
I
Bet it was I love you
Wipes the tear away
I don't think it's that kind of tear but you will need a tissue after that stream
I know about the rest of you but that face sure is cute. Yeah
Hmm or play buttons in the background. Oh, that's such good detail. That's like really good detail
That these small things that's good. I like I like the small details really mentioned something and then certain changes
Let's see what you guys thought
Please be careful. I'm on suck on my popsicle tail
How about you eat this ban? Well, I hold on a minute. I was a super chat. Thank you, kangel
Huh, you don't have to thank me and the fact I'd love to put it in my mouth again sometime
Bless bless amen amen we follow the cult of key angel
Bless bless this was awesome
Um
Oh stress is high I want mental darkness to go up but stress low
The more that go the more pain it feels so good. Oh my god. It's such a mercy
Thank god. This is just the game, huh? The bond between us is finally broken. Wait a flat lined
Huh
Huh what happened
Wait, no my friend wait because I she just perished
Wait, seriously if you ignore her messages
No, wait, she doesn't want me to be your manager
I got you a hundred k
freaking subscribers
And you don't want me to be your manager anymore because we didn't
Because that freaking was tell
I want my politician ending but it seems to be because it's actually quite hard. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. One two three four five six seven
Eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen sixteen seventeen eighteen ninety twenty one two three four
twenty four endings
bro
Yeah, I'm not throwing up a freaking emojis are clearly
You stop talking to her when you hit under key you literally in four days without answering a minute
I'm trying to get to help her achieve her goals. She said she wanted a million. I'm getting her a million. Okay, if that means
Pee Chan has to go a wee bit quiet. I'll go a wee bit quiet
Endurance room to get them all of I do not think so. There's no way wait. This is who've made the game
One two three four five six seven seven people came together to make this game
Honestly
That's fantastic
Seven people came together to make this game
Shout out to them. I am blown away by this game first time. I played it
I didn't really know what to expect, but I have to admit this is like 10 out of 10 experience
I understand a flat line and I didn't even get any ending at all really. This is the worst ending
That is
That's fantastic. I'm I'm not even like mad or anything click anywhere to proceed the end
Oh
Wait, it's real fan art. No way. They used real fan art in the game
That's absolutely amazing
That is so lovely. Holy crap. That's real fan art. Oh
I can't click around to see what these bottom ones are for some reason
But main pro that is
He's
Blown away absolutely blown away. Yeah, see this is what I saw when I booted up and I think this is windows vista
That is actually love. That's so lovely. What a lovely game. Like I know the
Yeah, this is I opened it up and I was like what kind of game am I getting into the warning
This game is set in a place sort of like modern japan
But also not any resemblance to real places entities living or dead is just coincidental
Do not try any of the more extreme or depressing
Action so I don't know what I haven't unlocked like action-wise, but
Sheesh
This game is big. Okay. Yeah. It's like you've read the warming properly, right? Yeah. Okay. Wow
Oh, at least you're back in
Oh, I give
Do you love me? I love you. I love love love you unhappy end world
Oh, maybe I don't want to spoil it. I'm gonna watch someone do all the endings because this is fantastic. I love this
Good game shout out to the day. I'm I'm so impressed with this game
I think it's a 10 out of 10. I love matters met a gameplay as well
Like kind of vtuber orientated esk type things. Um, I very I love the
manager
Like vtuber manager like fucking grooming route. That's hilarious
um
Wow, oh, so I've not unlocked all the fan arts as well
They're all zipped up in credits
Oh, there's a few I was gonna say there's no me seven
Oh, wait, no
producing staff one two
producing staff one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
and
Wow published by playground
I'm gonna have to look I'm 10 out of 10 game. I'll see if they've got anything else to play because that was
uh
like so good
Such a good game. Is she be live?
I could easily watch you 12 more hours of this. They said port and staff. Oh, my apologies. My apologies
Uh, I'm a dumb dumb. Can you read?
Uh
Yes, she is. Okay. I will redirect into she be is a shorter day
Today, but I'm sorting out some clip stuff and I'm I'm getting a freaking new
Manager in place and I need to set that up and once I've done it
I have like hardly any responsibilities and I love it. I don't want any responsibility anymore
Uh, right. Let me ensure
That we successfully redirect into sheepsters
That was so good. I did not expect that. Oh, she be playing a horror game
Mr. Hope's playhouse. Is that a horror game as bunny related? So I like it
Wow, that was such I thoroughly enjoyed that thoroughly enjoyed that. I know I know I got I didn't even get a successful ending
But that was good. Thank you for the stream 10 out of 10. That was fun. I had a lot of fun as well
um
Frickin hilarious
I enjoyed my state. I I'm glad you did. I do apologize. It's shorter tomorrow. I believe we are playing James Cameron's avatar, which is an eight hour
campaign and
Or maybe six hour actually if I zoom through it. Um, and then our multiplayer game of this week is
None other than old school runescape
That'll be an endurance stream as well
So you can pop in at any time if you want to make a fresh character you're more than welcome to
I will tell you what world we are on
We will pick a server that is not populated so we can all fit in because i'm not sure how many old school
Runescapers there are I will be doing a fresh account myself
And I will also be getting premium
But again, I will warn you tomorrow on jim's cameras avatar
But just so you know if you are interested in playing multiplayer games with me, uh old school runescape
I will see the server and we can do a questing together
I do recommend a new account because I wanted to do some
questing and then we'll get into the meat of trying to
Do 99 cooking is my first ever 999
So I would love to do that together. Okay
Right. Thank you so so much. Please enjoy sheebie sheebie weebie
Um, she's playing a horror game. I think and thank you so so much for hanging and I'll see you
Tomorrow won't I refling I better
Needy needy streamer needs to see you tomorrow
Thank you so much
Let she be takeover. Okay. Let let she be entertain you. Okay
Bye